did you watch the project veritas guy
that they originally had that was going
to uh
that had signed the affidavit saying he
was told to back date stuff or whatever
that okie was talking yeah did you ever
listen to the full interrogation of this
idea when he retracted his
yeah yeah i did so one of my worries for
the affidavits that and then watching um
reading through some of the judge
testimonies a lot of these affidavits
are people um they're
being truthful they're signing what they
believe to be true but the problem is
their observations are just not
bad like they think they are did you
hear what the guy said after
well after o'keeffe brought him on about
it he's like no i got mind controlled or
whatever by the interrogator
so if you listen to the interrogator
everything that they walked through was
like it was pretty obvious the guy's
claim was way farther than he ever could
have made
i disagree the guy literally walked
across the aisle to the destiny's like
hey if i'm
because because the guy had said when he
was across the office like i very
clearly could hear him saying like we
need to
post it or back date some of the ballots
and the guy's like hey can you hear me
over there and the guy like
doesn't even respond and he's like hey
hello and then i said oh yeah yeah i can
hear you now he's like okay
so the guy made it up in the first place
i don't think that he
made it up i'm not i don't think that
he's that malicious i think he probably
heard a word or two
and then maybe extrapolated and then i
probably ran with it after that it's
what it seemed like
that like two hour interrogation a guy
hearing something
and then being like i can't believe that
happened and then telling someone
is probably more accurate than a federal
agent coming in and saying sit down
and he says what did he what did he say
i'm scaring you right now
like why did what did you hear that
stuff yeah of course
that's that's so what do you think
happens when some regular like kind of
dopey dude is sitting there and a
federal agent is
kind of drilling him you didn't hear it
did you you can't hear it can you
you're right don't worry everything is
for you we're scaring you right now
so it was a creepy it was a creepy
recording it it wasn't it was totally
fair
the guy had originally stated that he
had heard crystal clear like across the
the
across his whole office and he'd heard
something he signed a sworn affidavit
under penalty of perjury sure and so did
there
plenty of people sign epidemics for a
lot of different things right sure sure
but um witness testimony is evidence but
it's not definitive
when it came time for him to actually
talk to the guy he walked back
almost all of his strong claims that he
couldn't hear the guy talking across the
house and maybe he didn't hear 100 he
was told to back date things that like
and i listened to the entire interview
it sounded pretty fair to me if the guy
had accurately heard it because
initially he did feel a lot more
confident when the guy asked a few
questions he started to kind of like
falter
and the statement and i know o'keefe
likes to clip out like five seconds you
know like palestine like yeah i'm
putting a little bit of pressure on you
because
that's what you do when you watch the
full thing so did we listen to all hours
it was it was not like i used to work
wait it was not what it was not uh a
calm reasonable discussion trying to
finding mission unbelievably calm the
guy spent half the discussion
like remember like the guy with the the
um the guy being in target was like oh
yeah i wanted a law enforce or i wanted
to go to criminal justice i went to
school for it i think i was like
oh yeah you know like that's so cool
like yeah you're probably smart you know
all of this like
seeing the police tactics the uh the the
investigator was playing good cop one
million percent the entirety it doesn't
mean he's not pressuring the guy and
playing upon putting memories in his
head he even said
we want to pressure you so that you can
you can make memories
and did you remember when he said that
right he said we want you
to you know when we pressure you this
way then you can form memories
i'm pretty sure exactly what he said was
that when we pressure you you're more
likely to remember what actually
happened is what he said
that under some pressure the truth will
come out or whatever it was ultimately i
think the argument is kind of pointless
on this one guys sure well
it is just this one because i noticed a
pattern for a lot of these affidavits
that what will happen is
that somebody will file an affidavit
saying like oh yeah like i saw election
fraud and then when it comes down to
like well what did you see it was like
well i was in this room and i think i
saw a thing and like the the
actual claim is actually way less than
the super extrapolated thing that ends
up on the affidavit is what it feels
like to me
i don't i don't buy it on the court
cases too i don't think the uh the
affidavits
uh go particularly far witness testimony
is evidence it's used in criminal court
cases all the time
i think the the best evidence we have so
far is the voter integrity project
are you familiar with matt brainard's
work so this aesthetician guy
yeah he's a data uh oh god i might have
if he was in front of michigan where he
tried to explain
no he wasn't allowed to testify in
michigan i think oh okay then that was a
different data center i think that was
right he he
yeah he went out there supposed to have
him and he went out there he's like i'm
going to testify there and then he's
like i was not able to testify
okay what he did was he i believe he
purchased
the publicly available data from several
swing states he then hired three call
centers
and he gave him a list of questions to
ask did you request an absentee ballot
did you send in an absentee ballot
things like that and he found
in a bunch of different circumstances uh
that was one of the things they did they
also cross referenced the national
change of address database with people
who voted
they found i think i could be getting
the number wrong was was it 20 000 in
georgia yeah
i think 20 000. 20 000 people in georgia
who had changed their addresses
voted in their new state and voted by
absentee in georgia
that's like he's got they've actually
published parts of the database you can
see the names
he actually he also found i think tens
of thousands of people who listed
commercial addresses with fake apartment
numbers in nevada i think it's like 11
000 or so
that's legitimate hard evidence so is
that going to show up in a court case
the fbi took it already so the fbi
proactively reached out to him and this
was
how long ago did this happen four days
three days why
how long ago was bar statement or you
said the fbi looked into things and it
didn't look like there was
barr said to date we have yeah but what
was that today well how long ago bar
probably that statement wasn't just a
couple days ago yes
we haven't seen evidence uh on a scale
that would have altered the outcome of
the election
okay something that affect the fbi just
reached out
reached out to brainerd requesting uh
this was reported in a few outlets he
mentioned it we'll see we'll see if
anything
it comes of it but this is one of the
reasons why there's a big backlash
between uh
people on the right and what bar had
said and why bar then clarified
the next day we are actively
investigating and we'll take any
credible report
you know or whatever so matt brainard is
probably
the best evidence but again it's not
definitive proof that
there was an outcome you know changing
that coming election i'm not saying that
you know maybe maybe the fbi did review
his data and they said
well these 20 000 are 5050 trump or
biden so it wouldn't have changed
anything
possibly the problem too is that like
and again i hate that i'm not maybe the
specific
specific thing but i know in front of
michigan they would testify that like oh
well here's evidence of voter fraud as
well
um there were 120 percent of the voter
people
yeah or not voter turnout like of the
registered vote or whatever here um like
they they would use these experiences
but the reality of what had happened was
well you know some people move the voter
registry isn't updated or some people
move here but like this isn't evidence
of voter fraud it's just evidence that
there needed to be an update and like
the right
history one of the biggest problems uh
in
trump's argument and a lot of
conservatives bring this up is when
they're like
you'll see a tweet where they say
there's 7 836 dead people on the voter
registration in this place
and it's like yes because they died and
they haven't been purged
yeah are you saying they voted because
that's a different you know so i hear
that a lot from that from the right i'm
like that's irrelevant
exactly proving that they voted yeah
yeah you if you have proof they voted
then all of a sudden we're like whoa
and there have been some instances but i
think uh in one i think there were a
couple where like somebody sent in a
melon battle and then died before the
election i think i i
was in like louisiana or something i i
misread something and tweeted like whoa
dead people voted and then i
went back and i was like ah they voted
and then died yeah
but there were some instances that some
mainstream it's found where there were a
couple dead people who
were found to have voted sure so the
issue there is
is there voter fraud yes and the
heritage foundation has a list of it
is it widespread to the scale that it
changed the outcome of the election
that's not been proven
sure that's the that's the best way i
can put it obviously the left will say
of course not the right will say of
course yes
the reality is there's evidence there's
crazy evidence but it's not been proven
and i don't think it will be to be
honest i don't i don't i don't think
uh and and you know a lot of
conservatives agree with this
that you have an apparatus that could
even investigate on this scale 150
million
votes to figure out who did or didn't
the
brainerd stuff the voter integrity
project is probably the scariest stuff
we have so far
there's a guy named nashon garrett he's
he's a
a college uh collegiate is that how you
say it
collegiate wrestler training for the
olympics he lived in arizona he moved to
tennessee
he got a phone call from one of the call
centers asking if he requested an
absentee ballot
he said no i voted in tennessee i moved
here a while ago to train for the
olympics
they said did you didn't request it you
did not submit one he says no i didn't
is it
somebody requested and submitted an
absentee ballot in arizona in your name
and so he then went public went on fox
news and said
that's not me i didn't do that that's
crazy
i'd like to see uh an investigation and
some prosecutions
and uh or at least at the very least
investigations maybe there's no
prosecutions because we don't know where
it leads to
leads to but if you've got people
changing their addresses
and then voting if if if this database
thing
on the national change of address
database from brainerd is correct and he
has 20 000 people in georgia who changed
their address
but voted in two different locations
either they voted twice or someone voted
in their name
we got to investigate that sure
especially if trump supporters are
outraged and demanding clarity
the crazy thing to me is that at a time
when this country is dramatically and
hyper-polarized
the democrats confident they're in their
win should be like please trump
take the resources you need to
investigate and compare signatures and
do what you need to do
so that we can then tell you we won
definitively instead
but they're doing that they're they're
not they're blocking it there's there's
there's uh they've been doing
all of these investigations or they've
had all these court cases and all these
different states
you know the court cases are not
investigations the dnc is countersued
and the aclu is counterfeit blocking the
trump lawsuits
so they're they're not cooperating and
they're arguing against it
you said that barr himself and the fbi
was it was following up you said that
list was turned into the fbi and these
investigations are working through these
things it's not like the investigations
are happening no no for sure i'm saying
the democrats should come out and be
like
yes absolutely please investigate i mean
i guess they're
they're on what they believe the merits
of the case are it's so ridiculous that
all this is doing is just tearing the
country asunder because they're
constantly challenging everything a
little part of the election process
it can only do the opposite that's not
true though you can draw stuff like that
like this for years
uh no until they can't find any evidence
of anything and then
biden wins the other countries long did
we have to listen to trump talk about
how obama was from kenya
like they could draw this out for so
long but there's
no problem sure there might be but again
processes can be understood on january
20th
whether or not there's an investigation
there's going to be an inauguration sure
and and and the investigation can carry
on and find let them draw it out
we went through three three and a half
years and we're still technically going
through russiagate because
adam schiff won't drop it and here we
are
and we all kind of just roll with it and
the pulitzer prizes and all the awards
and then we
we realized it was all of these people
testifying
under oath they had no evidence it
didn't happen wait which what thing
didn't happen
so you had the likes of was it like
brennan and clapper
you had people um schiff they were going
on tv saying
yes it happened we have proof wait what
happened
sorry okay because i've heard a lot in
the skiff when they were doing the
closed door testimony said oh no that's
not true i don't have any evidence
and so that actually got released i
think like october or something sure the
point
i'm i'm not trying to rehash all that
i'm just saying if i can go through all
that i got no problem saying
either we we let the investigations
happen and maybe we find something
maybe we don't but so long as people
feel that in good faith we are
taking their complaints seriously we can
prevent destabilization
of what is already an extremely
hyperpolarized i can understand that you
must understand on the other end though
there is a little bit of frustration
with what feels like endless
investigations
into nothing related to things like
hillary clinton or benghazi these things
how many hours of court hearings how
many months did we get drips about
hillary's emails buttery emails over and
over and over and over again like
i'm gonna disagree because i honestly
think that if you want every single
american to be rightfully enfranchised
if they have the right to vote
then you more than anyone else you and
all of the democrats should 100 percent
want every possible investigation
because we want this to be true
free full and fair for every legal
citizen in the u.s
sure and i hope that they do with their
investigations i hope they're pouring
their cases in front of the courthouses
that's fine
but they should be in advance the way
that all of this is played out it really
does
even the verbage they use the the it's
never when julianne giuliani's talking
it's never like i want to ensure that
this is a free and fair election i want
to assure that everybody's kind of it's
like we think we can find enough votes
here to change the outcome of this state
that's that's oh they usually
straight up asked sydney powell one of
the
in relief in the kraken lawsuit was
declare trump the winner yeah like
they're literally asking explicitly like
this is supposed to be the part they're
not supposed to say out loud you're
supposed to keep that quiet you're
trying to
but like so i i'm not saying that like i
hope the investigations are blocked if
they have merit
but um i mean it would i would
understand why some people would feel a
bit salty that investigators get dragged
out forever but
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you